we are creating thousands of jobs
I don't ever want to see it again hey
guys I'm off the grid for August but
Hollywood celebrities
are there any people who deserve your
attention more
[Music]
insurance companies
producers
and they're looking at us and using us
to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
I don't ever want to see it again
ever
and if you don't do it you're fired I
see you do it again you're gone
and anyone on This Crew does it
that's it and you too and YouTube and
you do you ever do it again
that's it
no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their because our
industry is shut down
it's not going to put food on their
table
or pay for their college education
that's where I sleep with every night
every night
foreign